même tout dans la matinée ce poste
frontalier est bien occupé mais la
circulation est surtout dense dans une
direction
increase depuis l'annonce d'une
mobilisation partielle en Russie on a
constaté une augmentation de 40% de la
fréquentation à ce point de passage
situé entre Saint-Pétersbourg et
Helsinki
pour ce jeune homme pas question
participé à cette guerre surtout qu'il
est à la fois russe et ukrainien avec
certains espaces aériens fermés et des
billets dont le prix ont explosé la
voiture ou l'autobus sont devenus des
options privilégiées le trajet est
souvent un aller simple
ce moscovite devra envisager une
nouvelle vie hors de son pays
à la frontière l'activité est continue
mais n'a rien à voir avec ce qui se
passe au Kazakhstan ou en Géorgie pour
entrer en Finlande et donc dans l'Union
européenne les conditions sont plus
strictes il faut d'abord avoir un visa
imprimé dans son passeport elle s'inqui
a annoncé son intention de restreindre
davantage l'accès à son territoire au
ressortissants russes muni d'un visa de
touristes faut dire que le gouvernement
finlandais fait face à d'importantes
pressions venant d'autres pays européens
mais aussi de ses propres citoyens
[Musique]
chaque mardi au coeur delsinkie
finlandais et ukrainien participent à
une manifestation contre la guerre menée
par la Russie Monster pour le Skype
pour cet homme la plupart des Russes qui
fuient leur pays ne s'opposent pas
nécessairement à la guerre mais plutôt à
la manière dont elle est menée des
Ukrainiens dit-elle pendant 7 mois ils
ont été silencieux aujourd'hui ils ont
peur pour leur vie
plus qu'une interdiction des touristes
c'est ukrainien demande aux autorités
finlandaises de fermer la frontière
ne pas se sentir en sécurité avec la
présence croissante de ressortissants
russe dans les rues de son pays
d'adoption
et pour certains est bloqué tous les
passages frontaliers n'est pas une
option
il faut encourager ceux qui ne veulent
pas participer à des crimes de guerre
dit ce député de gauche si la pluie les
restrictions ont détenteurs de visa
touristes l'élu estime qu'il faut
continuer d'accueillir les demandeurs
d'asile
ailleurs sur le continent l'enjeu divise
les différents gouvernements il y a
quelques semaines des pays alliés
avaient déjà grandement limité l'accès à
leur territoire la Finlande qui partage
1300 km de frontières avec la Russie
n'avait plus le choix de suivre le pas
la fin était devenue pendant les mois de
l'été à zone de 36 des Russes en Europe
c'est quelque chose que le gouvernement
Finlande est maintenant peut pas
accepter parce que c'est à contre notre
relation internationale européenne
ont réussi à entrer en Finlande avant
que la nouvelle politique soit appliquée
difficile pour ce jeune homme
d'envisager la vie qu'il l'atteint
première arrêt à Helsinki pour le reste
il ne sait toujours pas quelle route il
empruntera il sera fait le bouvier au
clair Radio-Canada